autre action à nantes aujourd'hui autour
d'un projet qui concerne toute la région
où s je veux parler de l'implantation du
futur aéroport sur le site notre dame
des landes en loire atlantique et
procédures sont désormais lancés mais
les opposants au choix de la plantation
l'aéroport ne désarment pas un millier
de personnes manifestaient cet après
midi à nantes
c'est fanny pasgrimaud cyril du tout
[Applaudissements]
pourtant le projet aéroportuaire notre
dame des landes prend de l'air le comité
de pilotage va passer au stade des
études dès le début de l'année 2004 une
phase active qui ne démobilise pas les
opposants d'autres projets par le passé
ont été ont été mises à mal par
justement par la population je pense au
carnet je pense
à d'autres à d'autres projets qui ont eu
ce même sort au delà de la dénonciation
qui concerne le déroulement du débat
public le millier de personnes est allée
au coeur de la ville pour toucher les
citadins le site est à 17 km de nantes
tous devraient se sentir concernés
sensibiliser les novices non plus au
niveau financier
eux ils vont avoir les retenues à de ce
nouvel outil suspect c'est clair que qui
va payer
la question est quand même là
aujourd'hui les 14 associations
présentes s'accordent surtout à leur
place et des hommes au centre du projet
envisagé les impacts sur l'agriculture
il faire un choix pour l'environnement
de demain
si vous voulez une exploitation faut
qu'elle reste un noyau faut qu'elle
reste intacte à partir du moment qu'on
commence à lâcher un petit morceau de
ceci de cela on est on est plus en phase
par rapport aux directive nitrates par
rapport à nos plans d'épandage par
rapport à tout l'ensemble c'est à dire
que nos moyens de production sont
complètement diminué et moi les moyens
de production c'est mes revenus il faut
impérativement que ce soit beaucoup plus
réfléchie que ça après deux heures de
défilé le rassemblement s'est dispersé
tranquillement mais leur combat continue
le collectif n'a pas l'intention de
lâcher prise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]